대표님께서는 송정동은 좀 어떻게
보시는지 제의의 성수동이 될 수 있을
거라고 생각하시나요
[음악]
저는 다음은 성수동
토박이신문 있을 거
같은데네 제가 그 동네에서 이제
초중고를 나오고 살면서 동네가 발전한
걸 봤어요 그래고 서울숲이 딱
들어왔을 때 어 이만한 공원이 서울
시의 한복판에 이런 생각이 있었고
일단 강남이 성수대 건너면 앞구정
이잖아요 맞아요 그래서 어 이런
지리적으로 좋은데 이런 숲을 갖고
있고 유유 공간이 크고 동네가 되게
좀 분위기가 있어요 옛날에 원래 가죽
수제 막 이런 거리 였기도 하고
공장도 많고 이랬는데 그래서 아 여기
는 어 추후에 한 5년 10년 내로는
뜨겠다 해가지고 저희가 들어가게 된
건데 그게 너무 빨라진 거죠 예 상상
이상으로 빠르게 진행된 거죠 그러면
직접 임차를 또 하고 계시기 때문에
가장 잘 아실 것 같은데 요즘
성수동의 평균 임대 시세는 좀 어떻게
되는지 어 요즘의 임대 시세는 이제
신축이 구축이나 그 좀 나닐 거
같아요 신축 같은 경우는 요즘 워낙
이제 매매가 많이 이루어지기도 했고
다시 올리신 분들이 많다 보니까 신축
기준으로는 1층이 평당 한 25만
원에서 뭐 많게는 뭐한 30만 원대
정도 나오는 거 같고요 평균적으로 좀
성수동은 또 특이한게 반지층이 많아요
옛날 집을 리모델링하는게 많다 보니까
반지층 같은 경우는 가시성이 좀 있다
보니까 조금 1층이랑 좀 비슷한
가치를 인정받는게 많아서 1 2층이
거의 한 20만 원 정도 되는 거
같고 그 위로는 그래도 한 10만
원대 단기 팝업도 좀 많이 들어오시
맞아 그것 때문에 요즘 들어가기가
힘들 힘든데요
임차보증이 아예 직접 팝업을 주시는
경우가 많이 생겨 가지고 사실 팝업을
하면 임대료보다 훨씬 수익성이 높기
때문에 요즘은 좀 연무장길 같은
경우는 좀 많이 그렇게 하시고 서울숲
쪽은 팝업이 많은 동네는 아니어서
저희 아뜰리에 길은 좀 임차를 많이
두시 편이세요 아네 땅값도 땅 값인데
임대료도 굉장히 많이 올랐잖아요 그죠
아무도 장을 좀 하시다 보니까 어
이거 월 다 바에 건물 하나 사는게
나을 수도 있겠다라는 생각을 분명히
하셨을 것 같은데요 생각을 해보신
적이 있으실까요 많이
했죠 정말 많이 했고요네 근데 제가
사실 부동산을 잘 몰랐었어요 그리고
금융을 활용하는 거에 대해서 너무 좀
부족했기 때문에 좀 그 타이밍을 좀
놓쳤던 거 같고 저희가 그래서 그걸
달 고 찾으니까 이미 너무 또 많이
오른 상황이다 보니까 저희가
접근하기에는 좀 산성이 사업성이 좀
안 나오다 보니까 이게 계속 늦어진
거 같아요 아 그러면 검토를 하신다고
하시면 1순위가 되는 지역은 지금은
성수는 조금 어려울까요 저는 그래도
아무래도 뭐 이게 동네이기도 하고 또
제가 지금 뭐 성수동 영보 스라고
얘기를 하고 다니다 보니까 무조건
이제 성수동을 제일 먼저 보고는
있어요 아 응원합니다
분
감사합니다네 아까 말씀 주셨다 피
오히려 그 건물주 분들께 역으로
제안을 오실 것 같아요 우리 건물에
좀 득점을 해 달라 근데 만약에 직접
알아보신다고 하시면 사업장 위치를
선정하실 때 어떤 점을 좀 중요하게
보시는지 저 같은 경우는 좀 고객
동선을 제일 먼저 봐요 아 이제
저희는 좀 아이템을 정하고 접근하는게
아니고네 공간에서 주는 느낌을 받고
그 아이템을 하거든요를 보시면서이
고객들이 어떤 생각을 하고 어떤
아이템을 찾을지 그래서 좀 고객
동선이 좀 좋은 데를 봐요 근데
그렇다고 해서 뭐 유동인구가 많은
데를 보는게 아니라 오면서 좀 감성
이런 걸 느끼실 수 있네 거리를
걸으면서 어떤 느낌을 받으실지 고민을
많이하고 그런 건물을 좋아해요 그러다
보니까 제가 구옥을 많이 좋아해요
오래된 느낌 느낌에서 주는 또 그걸
개발했을 때 저가 원하는 느낌이 잘
나오기 때문에 그런 걸 많이 좋아하는
편입니다 최근에 니카이 우동도 새로
오픈을 하신 걸로 알고 있는데 니카이
우동이 성수 남단에 위치하고 있죠네
맞아요 뚝도시장 쪽에네 그쪽은
전략정비 구역으로 제가 알고 있는데
혹시 그쪽을 업장으로 택하신 이유가
있을까요 첫 번째는 제가 이제 친한
대표님이 다이닝 하신 대표님이 계신데
전에 다른 매장을 하고 계셨던
자리였어요 거기를 이제 정리하게
되시면서 어떻게 하실지 고민을 해
가지고 어 그러면 한번 같이
해보자라는 이유가 있었는데 그중에
이제 지리적으로 봤을 때 거기가 뚝도
시장이라는 시장이 있어요 전통시장
같이 성덕정 길이라고 하는데 거기가
전략 정비 구역으로 돼 있어서 재개발
예정 지잖아요 그러다 보니까 임대료가
굉장히 저렴해요 그래서 성수동에서
걸어서 갈 수 있는 데에서 임대료가
저렴한 데는 거기밖에 없다 보니까 어
그럼 한번 해보자라는 얘기가 나오고
또 거기 2층이에요 그래서 이제
니카의 우동인 저희 그래서 거기서 해
볼 때는 이제 임대료가 저렴하니까
백화점이나 좀 몰이나 이런 걸 좀
염두를 해두고 오퍼레이션을 좀 짜고
어 여기서 2층에서 좀 자영업자들도
요즘 불경 기고 하니까 좀 교대 2층
칩처럼 2층에도 좀 잘되는 아이템 좀
아이템적용이라는 아이템을 좀 정해
가지고 좀 오픈을 하게 된 거죠 벌써
소분을 많이 타고 많이들 방문하시는
거 같던데요 맞죠
그요 감사하게도 저도 한번 꼭가
보겠습니다네 그 요즘
소액대부께서 성수 상권의 연장으로
송정동은 좀 많이 여쭤보고 계세요
대표님께서는 송정동은 좀 어떻게
보시는지 제의 성수동이 될 수 있을
거라고 생각하시나요 저는 안 된다고
보고 있어 개인적인
견해입니다네네 이게 상권으로 저희가
분석을 했을 때는 사실 거리적으로
이제 뭐 교통적 너무 불편하고
성수동이 하기에 좀 너무 멀어요네
맞습니다 성수동과 그 송정동 사이에
도로가 있는데 거기 도로 중앙에
중앙선이 있어요 그 가드레일 럼
막혀져 있는데 저희 상권으로 봤을 때
그런 중앙선이 가드레일이 있으면 다른
상권으로 구별을 해요 안 넘어간다
사람들이 그렇기 때문에 더 그렇고
거기가 이제 유동인구가 정말 없죠 예
가서 보시면 진짜 약간 무지 싶을
정도고 배우지도 어르신 분들이 많은
동네여자 fmb으로 저는 fmb 하는
사람이니까 fmb으로 봤을 때는 아
그런 상권이 되기는 매우 힘들다라고
보고 있습니다 그 저희도 검토를
했었거든요 아 실제로 검토를
하셨었어요 저희가 21년도 그때는
정말 지금보다 더 아 그러셨구나 근데
안 되겠다라는 판단이 났네 아무리
해도 이거는 10년짜리라는 생각이
들어서 fmb 10년을 보고 들어가는
건 아니니까 아네 맞습니다 저도
대표님과 같은 의견인데요 조금
단기적으로 투자를 진행하신다고 하시면
좀 무리가 있는 지역이라고 저도
생각을 하고 있습니다 마지막을 향해
달려가고 있는데요 성수동 임차를
희망하시는 분들이나 혹은 브랜드
런칭을 준비하시는 분들께 해드리고
싶은 말씀이 있다면 어떤 말씀이신가요
성수동에 임차를 들어오시는 분들에게는
조금 시간을 가지고 잘 찾아보시면
정말 매력적인 물건들이 많이 나와요
근데 좀 급하게 선택을 하시다 보니까
리스크를 많이 감당하고 오시는 거
같아요 그러다 보니까 진짜 뭐 두세
달 만에 닫는데도 많고 되게
안타까워요 그러면 조금 더 오래 가는
브랜드들이 많아졌으면 좋겠는데 개성
있는 것들이 조금 더 여유를 보시고
좀 사람들 많은 거 보고 갑자기 막
아 계약해야 있다 이러지 마시고
여유를 보고 오시면 그래도 더 갈
거라고 보는 상이니까 좀 내가 오래
갈 수 있을 때 어떤 자리가 좋을지를
보시면 좋을 거 같고 브랜드를 칭
하시는
분들에게는 유행보다는 정말 오래가는
브랜드를 만들기 위해서 좀 튼튼하게
쌓아갔으면 좋겠다 아 예 사실 저희도
처음에는 다 힘들었거든요 근데 저희가
이제는 6년 5년 막 7년 이렇게
되다 보니까 뜨는 거예요 더 언젠가는
이제 시기는 오니까 근데 내가 버틸
수 있게 좀 탄탄한 브랜드를 만드는게
제일 중요하다고 생각합니다 뜨게 된
비결이 혹시 뭐라고 생각하세요 비결은
뭐 주변에 제가 그냥 얘기한 건 그냥
존버가 답이다 그 내가 잘 좋은
아이템으로 맞아요 잘 하고 있으면
언젠가 한번은 뜬다 약간 이런 얘기도
하지만 많이 알려야 될 거 같아요
저도 많이 알리지 못했었는데 지금
많이 알리려고 노력을 하고 있고 좀
트렌드에 맞게끔 아이템을 트렌드에
맞게끔 맞추는게 아니라 snsn 뭐
이런 마케팅적인 걸 트렌드에 맞게끔
좀 공략을 하다 보니까 조금 더 좋
좋은 결과들이 나온 거 같아요 좋은
말씀 하네 대표님 목표가 분명히 있을
것 같은데요 목표가 어떤 거
말씀해주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 저는
처음에 서울숲에 들어왔을 때는 백종원
거리 장진우 거리처럼 저도 이제
김종영의 거리를 만들고 싶다는 뜻이
있었어요 근데 지금은 어려울 것 같고
서울 숲에서는 언젠가는 그런 거리를
한번 만들어 보는게 이제 작은 꿈이고
또 더 나아가서는 제가 fmb 이제
거의 20살 때부터 들어와서 했다
보니까 그때는 정말 환경도 안 좋고
대우도 많이 못 받았는데 좀 그런 걸
개선하기 위해서 저희도 노력을 하고
있어요 그래서 좀 튼튼한 fmb
회사가 되
직원들도 오래가는 그런 회사를 만들고
싶다 그런 꿈이 있습니다네 너무
멋지신 들 응원하겠습니다네 감사합니다
정말 마지막으로 지금 현재 운영하고
계시는 브랜드 중에서 딱 한 가지만
한 가지만 고르셔서 한가지 적극
어필하실 수 있는 시간을 좀
드리겠습니다 한 가지라면 키씨 어네
이유가 궁금한데요 아 정말 키 씨는
적으로도 그렇고 브랜딩이나 좀 IP
이런 관련해서도 정말 많은 애정과
진짜 정성을 쏟고 있어요 그래서 매년
저희가 이제 콜라보 디자인도 해서
캐릭터도 계속 만들어 내고 있고 좀
다양한 재미와 다양한 좀 분야랑
콜라보를 많이 하려고 하다 보니까
마음이 더 가는 브랜드고 또 메리트가
있는게 나중에 이제 어 다른 분들이
부키시 저희를 관심을 가져서 하고
싶다고 했을 때도 아 예 메리트가
있는게
제거하기 때문에 좀 다루기도 쉽고 또
언젠가는 저희가 또 더 커지면 공장을
만들면 공급해 드리기 너무 편하거든요
그렇네요 그게 되면 창업 메리트도 좀
있지
않을까네 어필해 주시면 되겠습니다 아
그런 점이 있으니 관심 있는 분들은
많이 연락 주시면 좋은 브랜드
많으니깐요네 감사합니다 구우 키씨뿐만
아니라 모든 매장이 정말 맛있고 또
좋은 공간이라 하루 날잡고 투어해
보시는 것도 저는 너무 추천드리고요
또 오늘 영상 보시고 아마 방문해
보시면 공간마다 특색과 좀 분위기가
다 다르고 또 그걸 잘 느끼실 수
있을 거라고 생각이 듭니다 오늘은
성수동 영보스 김종영 대표님과
함께했는데요 아무래도 실제 여러
브랜드를 운영하고 계시는만큼 임차인의
시선에서 바라보는 여러 이야기를
들으실 수 있었을 거라 생각합니다
건물 매입에서 그치지 않고 건물을 잘
구성하고 또 유지한 하는 것 또
나아가서 내가 원하는 시기에 엑시트
하는 것까지가 건물 투자라고
생각하는데요 어떤 입지에 어떤 건물이
되어야 임차를 잘 맞추실 수 있을지
고민해 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
오늘도 즐겁고 유익한 시간이었길
바라면서 오늘 영상 여기서
마치겠습니다
감사합니다
감사합니다 n